I actually it's funny I'm wearing makeup
today this is probably one of like five
times I've worn makeup working here
Barb's not sure I wear makeup when I
know I'm gonna be on camera I'm a huge
makeup addict
I've been wearing makeup for about like
five years straight I do love doing
makeup
I just hate taking it off so I don't
wear it very often I usually don't wear
makeup because I'm lazy and I like to
sleep I don't think I'm a makeup addict
my boyfriend would say differently he
thinks that I put a lot of makeup on I
don't think I do
I don't know what the exact term would
be a bit of tikkun it for eyebrows like
to fill them in eyeliner I have it in my
makeup bag I don't know I don't might I
use it for the right purpose but
eyeliner brush like is there like an
actual name for it is there it's an
eyeliner brush oh my gosh wow I'm so
impressed with myself right now
this is eyeliner brush nice eyeliner
brush but no I got I know things that's
great
I can't see it I don't that
oh boy I'm assuming powder foundation is
gonna last long yes I'm gonna eliminate
powder foundation I'm gonna go with
liquid foundation liquid foundation
because I would throw that out first so
you know you don't get acne
dick lipstick lipstick and lip gloss are
really similar process of elimination I
guess it would be liquid fundation my I
know my makeup I guess I just assumed
that like lipstick is closer to your
mouth so it would matter if it was old
more I don't know it was clearly wrong
okay I see you like people and like
online doing it on like the back of
their hand I know that it's not supposed
to be on your hand because that's a
different shade than your face neck or
your arm like one of the two on your
face because that's where you're gonna
put it maybe your neck I think I've
heard it's your chest because it has the
same tense and thinness as your face
I normally do neck or arm okay yeah your
job
well that's cheating that's already on
your face yeah that's not right Wow I
started so strong that is too many
brushes and I don't have that kind of
money I actually know this it's the
beauty blender and I only know this
because I don't use one Oh Beauty
Blender let's say a sector brush because
I don't know what it is it's the Beauty
Blender I help supply that make up
across evenly Beauty Blender it is the
one this is amazing Wow that isn't that
just a brush right
I think I have become happy I felt like
I was a failure a second ago and now I
feel like I know wish Oh cat eye cat eye
a winged eyeliner fierce that is what
it's an example of but I'm gonna say cat
eye
winged eyeliner yeah winged liner cat
eye same thing close enough right I
didn't realize that there were
differences I thought every time it just
went out it was a cat I say meow I never
use it I never do that ever I don't have
the skill yeah Oh
threading threading the reading reading
I've never gotten it done I heard that
it hurts
he's got my eyebrows waxed but now I
just pluck eggs and sheep threading I
don't do it scares me
rubbing I know that one for a fact
because it's something I'm terrified of
I do know this doing primary goes first
powder goes last primary foundation
concealer then powder so primer is
number one foundation is number two
that's at least what I do thank
concealer and then you do powder primer
foundation concealer powder primer
concealer foundation powders
I got it that should tell you something
that I don't even Oh God
oh I was right nice I'm doing it
correctly done boom what I think I did
better on this than I thought and that
either means I spend way too much time
on YouTube or on BuzzFeed I learned a
lot I learned some things I did not know
existed I feel like I'm like 50/50 I
think the rise I'm upset I'm real hurt
by this I knew more than I thought I was
for sure and feel very confident I
thought my makeup skills the quizzes
wrong
[Music]
you
[Music]